this is a this is an exciting uh thing
you're on the the top of the fiction and
the non-fiction bestseller list did you
ever think as a kid that anything like
this would ever happen to you absolutely
not no um
i i wanted to write before i uh got
sidetracked in the evil world of rock
and roll but
the devil's music devil music you've
been it's in there god bless devil music
but uh no i did it you know my mother
wanted me to be a southern writer so uh
i kind of want to do that and i got
sidetracked for 20 years in rock and
roll and then i decided right were you
uh were you a good student as a kid no i
was terrible and uh i was a catholic
student as well ouch yeah you know that
one catholic catholic and southern there
was boy there's some weird mixtures
going on down there and that so uh i
guess the first thing that i wanted to
after after that list came out relate to
is my english teacher that i made all
these and to say
so
i see it you shouldn't be using national
publishers to go
and your own teacher if you knew brother
colin you would uh
well you know what's funny is that you
do have this reputation as being this
incredibly laid back guy you're sort of
the uh
the the poster boy for for laying back
and enjoying life kicking back kicking
back and i was thinking to myself that's
a lot of pressure
because
it is because you can't freak out
you can't if you're at the end of the
dmv line and you got someplace else you
got to be jimmy buffett cannot go people
come on let's go
i don't like lines you're right but you
just kind of you know
you kind of take a couple of breaths and
you don't freak out yeah do you walk
around holding a margarita is that
something
no i if you had as many bought for you
or offered you as i have you know i kind
of that was getting actually tiring
wherever you go people are bri if you're
if you check into the hospital the nurse
would have a margarita
that's true i'm having an operation now
leave me alone usually they put tapes on
the gurney with you i had that happen i
woke up from surgery and there was a
demo tape of a song oh they want you to
discover them yes yeah now speaking of
songs
cheeseburger in paradise i've always
admired the song cheeseburger in
paradise because i thought who else
would write a song
about their love affair with a
cheeseburger
well it was you know songs come to you
on their spur-of-the-moment things so
were you really hungry at the time
what's the inspiration here i was very
hungry now what about the uh can we say
this on the air the the title of this
song yes you can
uh one of your songs my mother does not
like the song she doesn't like this song
i wonder why your mother doesn't like
why don't we get drunk and screw
what's your problem with that song
if you're if your mom's in the audience
do you do you not sing that song no
because uh it's on the list that i call
the list of songs i have to play or get
killed at the show and so it's
definitely on that list and my mother
winces a little bit but
you know that was a controversial song
when i wrote it and you know then came
rap so i'm kind of in a clear
it's one of those tame oldies now it's a
very piece of disney trash